actually actually even the top
medical experts are ignoring these
coronavirus guidelines
in a truly orwellian manner so
you saw yesterday we actually played it
on the show governor gavin newsom who's
new cellini he's trying to lock down the
whole state again
new cellini gets caught going to a very
fancy birthday party
which he said was outdoors but it
actually looks like it was indoors at
the french laundry
which is a michelin rated
extraordinarily expensive restaurants
like 350 or 400
a plate and he was there with a lot of
his friends and they were all shoulder
to shoulder and nobody was wearing masks
and everybody was swelling great wine
and no one was afraid of this virus that
they tell you
you have to live your life cowering in
fear of then he got caught he made an
apology
and he tried to you know move past it
and say okay
no big deal turns out it wasn't just
news in there
turns out some of california's top
medical authorities were there as well
so
here we had the california medical
association
ceo dustin corcoran
he was there the california medical
association lobbyist
janice norman we're both at this dinner
so you can't just say well the
politicians aren't listening to the
experts the experts themselves the
the top dogs at this medical association
they don't care about the virus they're
not worried of course they're not
worried
it has a very very very very low
mortality rate it always has but
especially now
if you look people are always talking
about how the cases are spiking
throughout the country and
it was such a slate of hand because the
media went from reporting on deaths and
hospitalizations to the cases
but look at the deaths of you see the
case is spiking up but if you look at
the deaths they're way
way way way down they're barely
registering on the graphs
good thing right we now have these
treatments we now have these vaccines we
now and we have actually for some time
had treatments for the virus
and yet these people tell you you've got
to live in fear well they do not
themselves
if that isn't orwellian i don't know
what is and by the way the last holdout
for them
are the masks and we talked a little
yesterday about why there's this divide
over the masks it seems conservatives
hate the masks liberals love the masks
and some squishy people say why do the
masks have to be political
and the masks have to be political
because they're a public matter when
you've got
hundreds of millions of people all
masking themselves like banditos in
public
that is a political question because it
affects how our society works how it's
governed how you can go into shops how
you can go into
access government services how you can
go into restaurants if you go to church
or if you can't go to church
obviously that is political i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you